signing credit card receipts are one of
those antiquated systems of
record-keeping that used to make more
sense but now through preservation of
only the tradition and not the purpose
has lost most of its meaning and
desperately needs to be replaced kind of
like that collection of VHS tapes you
still have from the 90s even though you
no longer have a VHS player to
understand this let's go back to the
credit card receipt glory days actually
we have to rewind a little bit before
that and talk about credit as a rule
people hate spending money but they love
getting stuff people will spend more if
they don't have to spend now but can get
stuff now and businesses love getting
more money even if they have to get it
later
this is where the idea of a tab or
credit comes from at first London cut it
were limited in where they could be used
sometimes of our would you be a pointer
token this group of you being a loyal
customer and lets you build a tab in the
bar or gas station would give you a
paper card as credit to AB you exclusive
stores within your area and a built in I
didn t Protection existed because in
most of these places everyone in the
town knew everybody so they would know
if the card wasn't held by the right
person but if they need for more
universal credit system came about
credit card issuers had to find some way
of securing their cards to protect
against fraud after all if you're from
Ohio and someone uses your card in New
York how is the merchant to know it
isn't you so this is where the signature
on the back of your card comes in the
merchant has you sign your credit card
receipt and it's supposed to check it to
signatures matched approved it really
you now even when that system kind of
made sense it had all sorts of blogs
comparing signatures properly takes too
much time the average clerk isn't a
signature expert and because your
signature is read on the back of the
card any industrial state could just
practice your signature Thursday before
actually going out on the spinning
street but this just it makes even less
sense now
because when's the last time anyone
actually compared your signatures like
that so why do we still have to sign it
all has to do with blade if merchants
don't have you sign and you decide that
you want to dispute the charge the
credit card company will make the
merchants reimburse you but if they did
make you sign they can say they use
reasonable fraud prevention methods to
verify that it was in that case either
you or the credit card company would
have to pay
but let's not get lost in business
buzzwords here it's important to note
that what everyone considers to be
reasonable fraud prevention is not
reasonable at all because they never
check if your signature matches anything
let me give you an analogy imagine bars
retired at the time it takes to
individually check if everyone's ID but
the government tells them they still
need to check everyone's when one
because the law says so
so in efforts of reasonable age
identification they ask everyone are you
21 and if they say yes they can drink
this system would help the bar prove
that they were trying to stop underage
drinking but the actual result would be
the equivalent of having no teach check
at all in that's like point your credit
card signature is equivalent to no
signature at all because it will never
stop everyone from using your credit
card so what do we do about it
well the good news is technology is
making fraud protection easier and
better than ever in Europe they rolled
out a chips and pin system which
requires a pin every time you try to buy
something this is at least a fact the
signing receipt and actually has some
real security in it but in America
although we've adopted the chip cards
we're still using their signature system
why you ask
one credit card company explained this
[Music]
if you can possibly ignore the dripping
condescension in the statement what it
boils down to is that you're only going
to get a credit card with actual
security when you run it and for that to
happen people everywhere need to realize
that the story of the signature is a lie
it doesn't protect you and worse it
breeds a false sense of security in a
system that needed to be replaced
decades ago
[Music]